sûrement que les continents de la
planète je pense dès les premières d'un
homme ou d'un parti qui pourrait voir la
france sauf tel qu'un cas jamais eu la
télévision
[Musique]
avouez vous aussi vous l'avez reconnu le
thème de l'inspecteur gadget créé en
1983 aux instruments les onze musiciens
du sacre du tympan avec cartoon les
artistes explorent les dessins animés et
films d'animations si je fais un
programme comme ça il faut que je fasse
un programme avec des musiques qui me
plaisent et dans lequel les musiciens
peuvent faire des choses aussi peuvent
s'amuser mais quand on l'a montait je
n'avais aucune idée du retentissement
que ces musiques et ce répertoire peut
avoir auprès d'un jeune public ce j'en
avais jamais fait au départ c'est
vraiment ciblé enfants et moi ce que
j'adore c'est quand il ya les enfants et
les parents à la série golo parce que du
coup pendant le concert les parents il
ya des trucs qui connaissent mieux mieux
qu'eux
que les enfants et vice versa
[Musique]
créée en 1998 par fred pallem avec des
musiciens rencontrés sur les bancs du
conservatoire de paris
le sacre du tympan on mêle musique
populaire et musique savante les
premiers dessins animés sont
essentiellement c'est essentiellement de
la musique de jazz mais bon là on fait
pas que du jazz il ya un peu de tout il
ya du rock il ya tout et des
particularités c'est qu'évidemment il ya
des thèmes avec des mélodies qui sont
très catchy qu'on reconnaît très vite
c'est toujours très très rythmé et la
musique pour les enfants c'est toujours
toujours très expressionniste quoi il
faut que les effets soient énormes
50 ans de musique retracé en une heure
de concert un spectacle pour les petits
mais aussi pour l'écran où le plaisir de
les coudes se mêlent vite au jeu de
celui qui reconnaîtra le plus vite c'est
pas la fin du monde exact
[Applaudissements]